-You know my next guest
as Peter Kavinsky
from the "To All the Boys"
franchise.
He has been called
the Internet's boyfriend.
So -- And everyone's
freaking out
that he's on the show tonight.
The third and final film
of the series,
"To All the Boys:
Always and Forever,"
begins streaming
on Netflix next Friday.
Here is Noah Centineo.
Noah, man, you are a good actor.
-Oh.
-You faked out
me and Dolly Parton.
-Have you you heard the truth?
-No.
The truth is pretty good.
-What's the truth?
-The truth is, I brought my cat
to a friend's house
but had to send him home
in a taxi
because he didn't get along
with my friend's dog.
-[ Chuckles ]
Wait, the cat by himself?
[ Laughs ]
Did he make it?
Did he make it home?
-He made it!
-[ Laughs ]
That is really funny, dude.
Oh, my gosh.
I'd love that
you trust the cab that much.
Like, "Just make sure this cat
gets to its home."
-But you know
what I thought about?
I thought about -- I was like --
I gave him -- Like, I tipped him
pretty heavy, you know?
I was like, "Hey, man,
he's an outdoor cat.
Just get it to the address,
open the door.
He'll know what to do."
He could have just driven,
like, two blocks
and then let the cat out,
and he didn't.
-That is genius.
That is a great --
That's a great story.
Oh, my gosh.
Well, last time
you were on the show,
you were here in studio,
and then everything shut down.
I haven't been able
to talk to you.
What have you been doing
with all your time at home?
Have you learned anything new,
picked up any new hobbies?
Nothing.
-You know,
it started off with, like,
staying up -- For some reason
in the beginning,
of, like,
the first lockdown in L.A.,
I stayed awake until 6:30
in the morning every single day
and listened to, like, lo-fi
and, like, cried
and, like [Laughs] just, like,
wrote a lot of different things.
-Yeah.
-It was really interesting.
And then I started --
I started doing this
because of my buddy,
Tom McCarthy.
I started doing
this thing called Wim Hof.
And it's, like,
diaphragmatic breathing.
Have you heard of it?
-No. Honestly, yeah.
I actually almost passed out
trying it.
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm serious.
Is that the thing --
-Yeah, no.
I have passed out doing it.
-[ Breathing heavily ]
-But, like, part of it's
cold exposure.
-Oh.
-And so, like, I started taking,
like, really cold showers
every single day.
-Yeah, I tried that.
-And it was like --
It was a whole --
It was a whole -- I don't know.
It was like a new world.
-But you took it
to a new level, though,
because we have a photo here.
It's you --
'Cause I was wondering,
you're in a garbage can
full of ice.
And I was like,
"Well, that's it.
He's officially cracked."
[ Laughs ]
It's like, "He's gone."
-"Goodbye, Noah.
He's gone."
[ Laughs ]
-I'm just gonna move
to the Swiss Alps.
-Dude, I mean, lookit.
What is going on there?
Talk to me.
-So -- So -- So I moved
to Florida last summer for --
I was gonna go just for
my birthday to see my dad,
'cause he lives in Florida
and some friends.
And I ended up staying there
for about three months.
And I was still doing
the Wim Hof daily.
It was like a daily practice.
But I got sick and tired
of cold showers,
and so I went to Lowe's,
and I bought
a 96-gallon trash bin
and would fill it halfway with
ice and the rest with water.
So that was my cold exposure
every single day,
like 15 minutes.
-I want to talk
about your new movie.
This is the third, and this is
the final of the series,
the final installment
of "To All the Boys."
I mean, can you believe you
and Lana through --
This is --
You'll never forget each other.
I mean, this is, like,
a major part of your life.
I mean, for the rest, right?
-[ Laughs ]
-I mean...
-Yeah. Yeah.
It was like we went --
It's been almost four years...
-Yeah.
-...you know, just her and I.
-And also just becoming famous
and all this stuff.
But the chemistry is phenomenal
with you guys.
Obviously, everyone
always brings it up.
But I heard there was a story
that you actually met --
Before you got the parts,
you met,
and there was not chemistry.
-Well -- [ Laughs ]
-Did you hear this?
-It was --
It was -- So, okay.
So, you audition
for a role, right?
You go into a room
with strangers,
casting directors.
You don't know them, and you're
auditioning for the role.
And so what I like to do
with my auditions is,
I low-key like to, like,
run lines
before the actual chemistry
and before the actual audition
with other people in the room,
because I feel like
it's a good way to break the ice
with, like,
reading with a stranger.
So I see Lana
at the chemistry read,
and I-I thought that --
I didn't realize
that she had booked the role.
I thought she was also
there chemistry reading
as one of three girls
like I was one of four guys.
And so I'm like, "Hey,
do you want to --
Would you maybe
want to run lines?"
And she's like, "No, I'm okay."
Like, in her head, she's like,
"I got this. I'm good."
-Yeah, what are you doing? Like,
"No, I got the part, dude.
You're the one
who's auditioning, buddy."
-[ Laughs ]
-"I already got the part."
Wow. That is so not smooth.
I love it.
-I forgot about it.
She brought it up to me.
She was like,
"Do you remember this?"
And I'm like, "No, I don't."
-Wow. And look at you guys now.
It's awesome, buddy.
Congrats on this,
and what a fun trilogy.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Noah Centineo
and Lana Condor
in "To All the Boys:
Always and Forever."
Take a look.
-Agent Covey.
-What's happening?
-Don't look at me.
Your mission,
should you choose to accept it,
is to meet me back here
in the lobby at 2100 hours.
We're going out.
-Where are we going?
-Don't look at me.
That information's classified.
-I'm pretty sure we're
supposed to stay in our rooms.
-Intel suggests
that the chaperones
are going to be at the hotel bar
getting absolutely wasted,
giving us a clear exit.
Do you accept the mission?
-I do.
-Very good.
I'll see you at 2100 hours.
♪♪
-Noah Centineo, everybody.
"To All the Boys:
Always and Forever,"
will be streaming on Netflix
starting next Friday.
Hey, say hi to your cat for me,
okay, bud?
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]